bonjour et 17,8 week-end une émission
dédiée à vos loisirs et aux idées
sorties ce week end c'est quasiment
impossible vous n'ayez pas entendu
parler des journées du patrimoine
d'autant plus que c'est la 30e édition
et dans quelques instants 2 recevront
notamment valérie josse de l'ensemble
vocal de saint quentin en yvelines pour
évoquer avec vous un concert qui a lieu
elle en cours dimanche
dimanche 15 dans les yvelines donc
beaucoup de choses à découvrir
évidemment à l'occasion de ces journées
du patrimoine et nous sommes notamment à
l'est nous sommes intéressés aux
services archéologiques des archives
départementales aurélia de bissy à
l'occasion des journées européennes du
patrimoine initiés ou amateurs pourront
découvrir à montigny-le-bretonneux
samedi 14 septembre la face cachée de
l'archéologie au cours d'une visite
commentée
les professionnels du service
archéologique des yvelines propose au
public de suivre le parcours d'études
des objets les objets n'arrive pas tout
nettoyé dans la terre et qu'il ya tout
un travail sur les objets qui est un
travail de conservation pour essayer de
l'accroître leur durée de vie on va dire
et aussi tout un travail de restauration
pour leur permettre pour permettre aux
archéologues de les étudier et aux
visiteurs de les apprécier lors
d'expositions les archéologues pour
comprendre les objets n'ont pas
seulement besoin delà même des mêmes
types de traitement que l'on va faire
pour présenter au grand public notamment
pour ce qui est du comblement des
parties manquantes ont les arts que le
qu'ils connaissent bien des objets sont
capables d'imaginer ce qui manque
alors que pour le grand public ont fait
un effort de comblement parce que c'est
plus facile sow d'appréhender un objet
lorsqu'il est quand même
ce que ball mais les restituer les
visiteurs pourront observer différents
objets et collections issues des
interventions menées sur tout le
département
certaines opérations récentes ont
d'ailleurs mis à jour des découvertes
étonnantes et unique
cette année on a fait de diagnostics et
les deux ou importer des récits juste à
fait passionnant alors la première
opération qui s'est déroulée aux mureaux
a permis de découvrir trois tombes et
dans l'une de ces tombes
il y avait un objet un petit poignard en
bronze tout à fait passionnant parce
qu'en fait c'est un objet unique en
france qui datait à peu près de moins
1800 moins 1600 milles 6 ans avant
jésus-christ ce qu'on appelle l'âge du
bronze et qui me paraît très mal connue
dans les aigus donc c'est vraiment ça
apporte une connaissance tout à fait
nouvelle et la deuxième opération qui a
eu lieu à cher là a permis de découvrir
vraiment quelque chose d'encore plus je
dirais unique 7 des restes humains et
ils ont été datés ces restes humains et
ils seraient de moins huit mille ans
avant jésus christ est en fait en gros
le plus ancien vinoy en fait qu'on
aurait puisque on a des objets bien plus
anciens ou en quatre cent mille ans mais
en restes d'individus de personnes ce
serait le plus ancien
quelques deux cent quarante mille objets
inventorié de toutes époques et de tous
types de matériaux sont conservées dans
les réserves du service archéologique
des yvelines continue à parler des
journées européennes du patrimoine avec
les choristes de l'ensemble vocal de
saint quentin en yvelines sous votre
direction valery dos bonjour jean pierre
bonjour vous êtes télé ridant fondateur
de l'ensemble vocal à vous proposer un
programme de musique médiévale et oui
l'étonnant sarthe
et oui pas pourquoi donc la commanderie
de lavilledieu c'est bien évidemment
créé dans les années
le sang et donc nous avons nous sommes
partis à la recherche de manuscrits donc
bien évidemment les la musique était pas
encore imprimé et nous feront découvrir
au public grâce à ses nombreuses
découvertes la musique qui se faisait au
12e et au xiiie siècle et dont les
pèlerins ont forcément entendu sur le
site de la ville dieu puisque en fait il
ya trois thés mais trois thématiques sur
l'année là sur la journée de patrimoine
c'est si j'étais pèlerins mais ça se
déclinera à trois autres moments de
l'année en descend si j'étais moines
avec les chansons bien évidemment de
noël et puis au mois d'avril sa terrasse
si j'étais musicien puisqu'il y avait
les trouvères les troubadours donc
découvrir dans la journée du patrimoine
le répertoire racine ans à la musique
médiévale
ah oui c'est pour moi sans la passion
loin s'est éloigné exactement ce sont
des sonorités superbe s'ils sont eux et
surtout ce sera un concert participatif
puisque on proposera au public
d'apprendre aussi de comment on dansait
la pavane à cette époque là etc
c'est quoi la permanence a passé une
danse c'est une danse où on se pavaner
en étant le cortège à deux et on fera le
cortège de la tavannes dans la chapelle
de lavilledieu donc c'est des moments
sarah est ce que ça ressemble au dans ce
qu'on connaît un peu dans celle des cons
non non non alors le par l'audois on se
tiendra tiendra pas on l'a revue faire
quand tu y aura des moments où montra
des rondes autour du public le public
sera très mobilisé et c'est une
découverte ludique de la musique du
moyen âge parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pas forcément quelque chose sur lequel
on connaît donc là on va découvrir
combien de choristes ont mobilisé alors
pour eux comme d'habitude les 32
choristes de l'ensemble vocal c'est
toujours une femme homme femme pas
encore à parité puisque nous recherchons
des messieurs on va en parler après mais
je manque si c'est mixte effectivement
pas widow en musique médiévale on peut
avoir bien évidemment là on fait par des
hommes ou par des femmes tout à vienne
nous avons des morceaux qui chante en
former ensemble et des morceaux qui
seront entre guillemets interpréter que
par les dames comme dans les monastères
de femmes ou comme par les hommes
c'était l'époque la mixité mélangez pas
à balancer pour ça parce que la mixité
n'est pas si t'es pas une notion
forcément courante on va dire ça comme
ça aurait coûté 1
un extrait du concert no qui sera donné
ce dimanche à 17h si je ne me trompe pas
la commanderie des templiers à elancourt
là si on peut entendre un petit sont
parfaites
oh
alors on a entendu effectivement c'est
très religieux totalement il n'y a pas
que des chants religieux on chantera
aussi un boom tourdion où on dansait et
on buvait en même temps mais bien
évidemment à l'intérieur de la chapelle
marchent dans une rue en sens inverse
sonorité assez cristalline et on se dit
que dans une commanderie des templiers
chapelle la commanderie on aura ce sont
un peu cristallin c'était encore mieux
puisqu'elle a un coût voilà c'est
merveilleux c'est vraiment un côté
acoustique aussi qu'on fait découvrir
cette chapelle sont divinement et on a
vraiment l'impression que les voix
résonne de partout tout à fait ça va
bien faire à cette époque là et oui
alors ça c'est pour le concert de
dimanche un petit mot sur la saison à
venir à aller la saison allait alors
bien évidemment à tout honneur le
monsieur qu'on respecte tous ces
messieurs poulenc
or 1963 c'était sa date où il a fini sa
musique et nous lui rendrons hommage
avec l'école de musique de guyancourt
ton pas règne chaque année avec des
élèves qui vont chanter des oeuvres de
lui et avec l'ensemble vocal nous nous
interpréterons plusieurs morceaux pour
noël aux environs du 7 décembre
ensuite bien évidemment on continue sur
le côté solennel de la musique
conduisant plaire mais je vais lui
donner la parole dit c'est une
discussion entre femmes et solennelle et
bien oui disons que on essaye tous les
tous les ans d'avoir un programme que
l'on place sur des sur des associations
extérieures ou même du site de saint
quentin en yvelines
et cette année le rotary club
va nous prendre une commande pour
chanter à l'église de châtillon ça sera
la petite messe solennelle de rossini
oms export oui enfin le style rossini
c'est pas mal non plus alors vous êtes
le président fondateur de la seconde est
tous les deux d'ailleurs cet ensemble
vocal de saint quentin en 95 alors
pourquoi avoir créé un ensemble vocal
disons qu'à l'époque forcément ça nous
manquait parce qu'à l'époque bien
entendu chaque commune avait sa sa
chorale et on était un certain nombre à
vouloir faire davantage à creuser un peu
tout en restant sur le statut amateur et
pour ce faire il fallait travailler avec
des professionnels qui nous faisait
travailler la voix et qui nous faisait
travailler les différents la différents
répertoires disponibles et on en a parlé
un jour comme ça puis on a dit ça serait
pas mal et on a rencontré la communauté
d'agglomération et c'est pratiquement
pratiquement 20 ans et oui aisément dans
deux ans ce sera exactement ça sera les
attend et là on va nous promet une
superbe alors avant le 20e anniversaire
vous recherchez des cauris vous l'avait
dit et lyon ou à l'appel aux messieurs
et bien évidemment vous un évidemment
sur la ville nouvelle nous avons quand
même beaucoup de messieurs qui aiment
chanter forcément mais qui ne viennent
pas forcément réseau vers la démarche le
jeudi soir alors le jeudi soir tous les
tous les jeudis nous répétons au théâtre
de saint quentin donc c'est simple à
trouver c'est facile d'accès on peut
garer sa voiture et surtout on peut
venir se détendre tous les jeudis soirs
bien évidemment il faut un petit peu
savoir chanter et surtout à vous on va
mais vrai qu'on est un petit peu c'est
le un petit peu qui bloque tout dire que
voilà il faut chanter juste il vaut
mieux quand on chante dans sa salle de
bains que sa g reconnaît bel air mais
voilà alors donc si messieurs mots
d'amour reconnaissent les gens sont cons
chanter sous la douche le matin c'est
bon vous pouvez faire partie de la
chorale adresse directement
il est à les sauver cette information il
ya un prof de chant qui forme les
messieurs et les dames
bon voilà donc si vous voulez participer
à l'aventuré ensemble vocal de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est donc tous les
jeudis soirs au théâtre de saint quentin
et je sais pas si un petit bandeau qui
est affiché sur le pour le site internet
mais sinon c'est les trois doublés poing
levé est ce qu y point com
voilà pour toutes les infos ensemble
vocal de saint quentin en yvelines merci
à vous d'être venu sur le plateau du 7-8
week-end merci et avant de nous quitter
ben je vous propose
regardez ces autres idées pour les
journées du patrimoine
m
mais voilà toutes les infos à retrouver
sur le site du cas ce que on va évoquer
maintenant le bilan du tourisme dans le
département lorrain était tardif une
crise économique est bien cela n'a pas
découragé les touristes bien au
contraire le bilan de cet été est très
positif à certains lieux qui dépasse
même des batman des records c'est le cas
du château de bretagne breteuil violente
en reste avec la météo maussade du mois
de juin la saison avait mal commencé
les touristes ont attendu l'arrivée des
beaux jours de juillet pour sortir de
chez eux
bilan de la période dans le département
7 à 10% d'augmentation par rapport à
l'été dernier tous sites confondus
les gens prennent des vacances de plus
en plus courte alors forcément un
département que nous sommes qui est un
département de loisirs en bénéficient et
puis les parisiens par exemple qui ont
pas envie de faire beaucoup de voitures
viennent chez nous c'est assez dépaysant
c'est pas loin et c'est même accessible
si on le souhaite en transports en
commun en tête des sites touristiques le
château de versailles
les entrées ont progressé de 8% sur les
mois de juillet et août par rapport à la
saison dernière
l'autre star de l'été c'est le château
de breteuil + 20% cette année avec 12000
visiteurs en juillet les musées en
revanche ont enregistré une légère
baisse de fréquentation
un petit point noir est à noter aussi du
côté des hôtels qui tourne surtout grâce
aux affaires la saison estivale est
toujours plus compliqué pour
l'hôtellerie puisqu'il ya moins de
réunions d'affaires
et puis on assiste là la crise on l'a on
la subit pour l'hôtellerie on assiste
vraiment un développement des
fréquentations dans le deux étoiles et
moi dans le 3 et 4
les gens dépensent un petit peu moins
les responsables du tourisme insiste
dans l'ensemble la saison reste bonne en
attendant les chiffres précis on peut
d'ores et déjà affirmer que le
département a fait mieux que l'année
dernière il avait reçu plus de deux
millions et demi de touristes
et voilà la direction maintenant
maurepas pour la deuxième édition du
festival pop rock coup d'état retour sur
une ambiance enflammée avec eiffel
sergent garcia et poni hoax
eiffel sergent garcia jenifer ou encore
axelle red
voilà quelques uns des artistes qui
étaient sur la scène du festival propre
coup d'état vendredi et samedi à
maurepas
malgré une météo un peu capricieuse en
deux jours le festival a accueilli plus
de 2500 personnes
la sergent garcia c'est pour lui ah
ouais et l'ambiance et parce qu'on
habite à côté que c'est sympa qu'un
petit festival comme ça donc du côté des
artistes la scène du coup d'état est
l'occasion de présenter leur dernier
album venus tout droit de bordeaux
le groupe rock et celle poursuit sa
tournée avec foule monstre leur
cinquième album je pense ce soit en 1h15
qu'on va jouer après 14 15 titres voilà
et qu'on va jouer sûrement 8,8 de nouvel
album on a fait des emprunts et musique
on adore celle durable dans l'idée de
cela mais on ne peut pas la musique rap
mais on emprunte et aussi on a vachement
ghz et de synthés et debout machine de
boîtes à rythmes et c'est ça n'a jamais
fait auparavant
le quintet parisien poni hoax revient
avec son troisième opus state fois il a
été réalisée très différemment on avait
fait des prises et après on a on a
travaillé à la maison on arttu des trucs
des structures et on a beaucoup produit
derrière et là en fait on avait répété
même parfois jouer les morceaux concert
avant d enregistrer donc on a vraiment
on a beaucoup moins travailler après on
a travaillé sur le moment quoi prendre
pendant les prises et après on a moins
on a moins travaillé derrière donc du
coup effectivement s'il est différent
des autres
sergent garcia créateur du célèbre salsa
muffin de retour sur les scènes
françaises après deux ans de tournée
internationale présente una y otra vez
c'est un album qu'on enregistrait qui
est sorti il ya deux ans maintenant on
l'enregistré entre quatre pays la france
l'espagne cuba et la colombie avec une
grosse partie en colombie il ya 27
musiciens de sur cet album dont dix
musiciens colombiens de la scène la
nouvelle scène
colombienne c'est un album qui est un
groupe un petit peu de beaucoup d'époque
de sergent garcia avec toujours cet axe
entre la musique latine et la musique
jamaïcaine le reggae la salsa toujours
présent mais avec une couleur vachement
colombienne on pourrait même dire astro
colombienne avec des morceaux de cumbia
avec les morceaux de musique afro
colombiennes inspirées du pop et rythmes
du pacifique c'est un pays la colombie
qui a une richesse culturelle énorme qui
a des rythmes indigènes qui a des
rythmes afro qui a sept cumbia qui est
extraordinaire pour faire danser les
gens
et du coup il ya un petit peu toute
cette ambiance là c'est le sergent
garcia en colombie quoi
avis aux amateurs sergent garcia sortira
fin octobre une anthologie de 2006 2010
double dvd et sera au bataclan 24
janvier prochain
à la marathon n'est pas seulement le
jardinier en chef du domaine de
versailles il est aussi celui qui aime
raconter les histoires les grandes comme
les petites écoutez plutôt
alain baraton presque comme un roi ce
dimanche dans les allées de versailles
le jardinier en chef al allure altière
l'homme aime partager les secrets de son
domaine lisons les petits secrets
variante honnête aimé jouer s'amuser
dans cette grotte on dit même que c'est
ici qu'elle rencontrait secrètement
force elle devant un public forcément
comblé le jardinier en chef
excellent orateur décrit cette scène le
roi louis xiv opéré est en convalescence
à saint-cyr-l'ecole chez les soeurs lui
qui composent une muse et une côte et
musique
quelques temps plus tard endel le musée
sphère du roi georges premier
l'angleterre de passage à versailles en
temps la muzelle de bd et apprend les
paroles de mademoiselle de brienon il
retourne en angleterre avec god save the
king
eh bien oui ma gueule celle de king a
donc été créé à versailles pour la fif
fou du roi au plomb est question musique
alain baraton en connaît un rayon pour
les amateurs de contrepèteries il
reprend cet air bien connu qui met en
scène un curé il court il court le furet
je vous laisse deviner le sens de la
phrase c'est une époque où quand on ne
peut pas trop parler on raconte des
dites vous bien que chaque fois que vous
avez appris une chanson ancienne il ya
souvent beaucoup de connotation un peu
douteuse par exemple au clair de la lune
- mon ami pierrot et bien écoutez donc
les paroles de cette chanson qui date de
quand vous apprenez que la voisine
fabriqué à l'eau allait donc vous
renseigner sur le terme de briquets et
vous comprendrez qu'on vous a appris les
saloperies à gré
des intrigues les intrigues amoureuses
qu'on n'imagine pas forcément comme quoi
comme le petit cabanon de jardin en
palliant la française fait qu'ils
servent et qui servent évidemment roi on
a une vision une autre vision de
versailles avec les commentaires qu'on a
eue sur cette visite là on voit les les
jardins autrement et on voit l'histoire
autrement j'aime bien parmi toutes les
anecdotes rappeler l'histoire ou les
origines de la construction du château
ou du petit trianon et j'ai rappelé par
exemple que le petit trianon ce matin
avaient été construits non pas pour
permettre à louis 15 d'être au plus près
des savants qui viennent travailler la
beauté dans ce lieu mais pour permettre
à madame de pompadour de s'accaparer
pourrait le sol leroy et éviter qu'ils
ne se disperse trop dans le lit de
quelques confuse à nos châteaux un
jardin ne peut pas être beau ne peut pas
transmettre une émotion si on n'est pas
capable de connaître son histoire et son
parcours une visite exceptionnelle et
pleine d'esprit dans le cadre de la
deuxième édition de paroles de
jardiniers alain baraton en est le
parrain une visite ponctuée donc
d'anecdotes privé mais qu'il ne fait pas
oublier la magnificence de versailles en
matière de jardins le domaine en toute
humilité ce sont 43 kilomètres d'allées
350 mille arbres et un million et demi
de fleurs la petite et la grande
histoire ne peuvent être ici que des
mesures assez incroyable alain baraton à
leur rencontre avec un autre personnage
il s'appelle jean luc legrand il est
boulanger à houdan et participe à
l'émission de m6 le meilleur boulanger
de france apporterait signé claire
cambier
il est 8 heures jean-luc est aux
fourneaux depuis maintenant plus de
quatre heures des horaires difficiles
mais ce travail le passionne depuis
maintenant 30 ans sa boulangerie y est
situé à houdan mais la renommée de
jean-luc a largement dépassé les
frontières de sa ville depuis le début
de semaine lundi on a pu les découvrir
dans l'émission la meilleure boulangerie
de france sur m6 inscrits par des
clients il fait partie des 84 boulanger
sélectionnés dans l'hexagone
je me suis retrouvé dans la sélection
des musiques croyait pas trop je me
demandais ce qui se passait je pensais
qu'il y avait plusieurs boulangers de ma
ville et non vous êtes le seul des
yvelines donc la grosse pression parmi
les épreuves il a dû préparer des
spécialités de la maison vous présente
la nook atos et une brioche que j'ai
fait pour l'émission donc c'est une
brioche au nougat avec des briseurs de
nougat de l'abricot sec - le pardon et
des noisettes torréfiées une brioche
qu'il a créé lui-même face à deux autres
boulangers il a su convaincre le jury
prochaine étape la finale ile de france
diffusée ce vendredi à 17h35
pour le moment il savoure sa nouvelle
notoriété des clients affluent de paris
ou encore de chartres pour jean-luc
c'est aussi le moyen de créer de
nouvelles vocations
ça va faire découvrir notre métier parce
qu'il a été beaucoup dé l'été à une
époque par les jeunes parce que c'est un
métier difficile pour travailler le
week-end pour travailler la nuit tout
mais en même temps c'est un beau métier
je me lève le matin je suis heureux de
travailler quoi jean-luc cherche
d'ailleurs à grossir son équipe l'appel
est lancé
victoire au nom lors de la finale à cet
artisan continuera à réaliser ces gestes
quotidiens avec plaisir on passe des
bakassi kg elle appelle la machine les
divisent pour la répartition des postes
le sang sur une un surhomme peut être
pas mise en passionné oui voilà bonne
chance à ce boulanger 2 aux dents alors
vous le savez en ce moment c'est le
temps des forums des associations doter
ces deux rendez vous qui ont lieu samedi
donc l'un à magnifier les hameaux et
l'autre à guyancourt et pu noter aussi
qu yvan le bolloc'h donnera un concert
gratuit à guyancourt à la fin de l'après
midi puis vous allez peut-être aussi
profité du week-end pour aller au cinéma
et bien les saint-quentinois ont vu des
films et ils donnent leur avis ce sont
les sorties ciné
c'est un très beau film magnifique
et émouvant c'est un très beau film qui
reflète
l'histoire des noirs africains noirs
américains une très belle histoire
touchante des personnes qui servent tout
simplement
les hommes
les personnalités célèbres qui restent
dans l'ombre tout au long de leur vie
est d'autant plus là pendant une période
de
de l' esclavage qui était vraiment
présente aux états unis très bien sa
retraite l'histoire des droits civiques
enfin ça m'a bien plu c'est à la fois
familial une histoire familiale et en
même temps ça situe dans le contexte de
l'époque va jubiler mais
c'est un film très sombre
qui montrent une facette
du travail des douanes c'était très
intéressant c'est très bien avoir un
petit peu déçu quand même un peu trop
long peut-être pour raconter l'histoire
de trois loser qui rêve de devenir
riches et c'est pas aussi bon que ça bon
il ya des gros bras ya du muscle on
s'amuse un peu mais on s'ennuie aussi un
petit peu c'est pas aussi excellent que
ce qu'on peut attendre voilà et puis
notez aussi ce nouveau rendez-vous que
propose la rédaction tous les mercredis
c'est la chronique cinéphiles et les
directeurs de salles de cinéma qui vous
donnons également leurs coups de coeur
c'est donc tous les mercredis dans
l'émission cas ce qu'a laissé ses tweets
week-end est terminé merci de votre
attention n'oubliez pas et évidemment
que ce week-end ce sont les 30è journées
européennes du patrimoine donc bon
week-end culturel et à très bientôt